[Music]
hey folks
you're here
[Music]
sometimes it can be helpful
in that
in a sense to
complete a puzzle we'll see how far that
goes
[Music]
nice music we got going here
[Music]
hey
wow
[Music]
a thousand pieces
[Music]
that's going to take me
15 minutes to turn all the pieces up
[Music]
[Music]
okay double time folks
i guess the
orchestration doesn't want to agree
in the double
the time piece that we put together
jeremy did a great job great sherry
i heard you're gonna offer me excellent
no thanks
oh great
bye sherry
it's okay
[Music]
yes i tried putting all the side pieces
over here yeah
did you like put the colors together
[Laughter]
yeah that's what i try to do here with
all the ends
unsuccessfully of course
oh a flower
[Music]
wait oh
oh
[Music]
got one
got one
okay
all
right that's a good sign
oh
yes yes
oh that's great
[Music]
hey mike
what do you think what do you have to do
about
um my quarter oh
got a couple
all the pieces together
i have no real reason for being on this
staircase right now
[Music]
[Music]
i need your
support
[Music]
okay
[Music]
wow
this is exhausting
[Music]
excuse me
okay
[Music]
well time's up
[Music]
folks over and out
hello hi what do we have here a puzzle
have a seat
okay
i got a lot done for you here
i got i really i really got you you know
started
and uh yeah with a bunch of uh i did
yeah okay like three questions
[Music]
no my time is up i'm
i'm actually but this music's gotta go
yeah that's what you want to call it
oh my god
stuck in my head
okay